all the work I've done over the years
with different NFL and other
professional athletes this guy comes in
he's young I mean he's like 26 years old
he's been he been the league a few years
but not you know he wasn't an old guy in
the league by any stretch and his sweet
little wife and uh they they drive in a
used van
wow and they come in and they go like
Dave you're going to kill us we've
messed up and I'm thinking they're going
to tell me they've blown all their money
and he goes I I you're just gonna be so
mad at me and I'm like number one I'm
not gonna be mad at you regardless how
dumb you are but what did you do I mean
did you do something dumb and he goes
yeah we've got all our money in savings
account
and I said uh how much money do you have
in savings account uh 36 million oh whoa
and I'm like no I am not going to yell
at you I'm going to hug you you have 36
million dollars and the only thing you
did wrong was you didn't invest it no
you you get a hug